-Welcome back.
-Thank you.
It's been a long time.
-People.
-I haven't -- yeah,
there's humans, there's people.
Yeah, that's right!
-I love it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You love it, right?
-I love it.
-It's an amazing --
-Yeah, it's lovely.
It's lovely.
Yeah, of course.
-It's an amazing feeling.
Well, I want to say
you're making
your Broadway debut.
-I am.
-And I'm very excited.
I cannot wait.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And not a little challenging,
but you're doing Shakespeare.
You're doing "Macbeth"?
-Yeah.
-Wow!
-We can say it here, yeah?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What does that mean?
Yeah, you can say it.
-Well, people are loathe
to say it in the theater,
because it's --
-Oh, it's superstitious.
-Superstitious, yeah.
You have to -- If you say it in
a theater, you have to, like,
turn around four times,
spit over your shoulder,
and go out the door
and come back in.
-Yeah -- Yeah, exactly right.
Yeah, no.
-Take your pants off
or something.
-In here, in the TV show,
you can say --
-You can say it.
"Macbeth," "Macbeth," "Macbeth."
-"Macbeth," "Macbeth,"
"Macbeth."
But you and Daniel Craig?
-Yeah, I know.
-James Bond -- that's my guy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I know, I know.
You're a big fan.
I know.
-I'm an uber fan.
Like, we --
I was his last interview
as James Bond.
-Isn't it great?
-We had a martini together.
-Aww.
-Yeah, it was --
-Isn't he lovely?
-It was actually --
it was emotional.
-He's one of the soundest people
I've ever met.
-He's the great -- Oh, he's --
Did you get
to rehearse yet or no?
-We've -- We just did
a couple weeks, yeah,
sitting around,
talking about it,
and he's just so
down-to-Earth and lovely.
We bonded over a pencil --
-Pun intended.
-Oh!
-Thank you.
-Yes, completely intended.
-That's my style.
-Steal my joke.
"We bonded.
We bonded over --"
-I have to steal yours.
I've none of my own.
[ Laughter ]
-Well, if it gets that reaction,
you won't want to steal it.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, fair enough.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
But what did he -- did you --
Now you can't say the word.
-Pencil sharpeners.
Parers.
You know, pencil sharpeners.
Like, stationery.
-Really?
-Yeah, he loves --
he loves a good pencil parer.
[ Laughter ]
So do I -- yeah.
-Pencil --
-Sharpener, yeah.
-Yeah, like the --
-It's very satisfying, isn't it?
-Yeah. Like, the -- now they're
battery-powered and stuff.
And electric.
-Yeah, yeah.
It's very exciting.
[ Laughter ]
-No, no, no, no, no.
The old crank.
-I just ruined
Daniel Craig's reputation.
[ Laughter ]
The coolest man in the world.
-The coolest man.
Imagine if a scene
in "James Bond" is him
sharpening a pencil.
[ Laughter ]
No.
But even he would do it cool.
-Yeah, yeah.
-He'd, like, come in,
shirt off, and, like --
-Yeah, yeah.
-Bzzz!
-He's got cool
coming out of his pores.
It's sort of effortless,
isn't it?
-Speaking of effortless --
it's a good segue for me.
You're fascinating and fantastic
in "Passing."
-Oh, thank you.
-Your film.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Thanks a million.
Means a lot.
-You're getting rave reviews,
and awards buzz
and all that stuff.
Do you listen to that or --
-No. Can't.
-No.
-No, get too nervous.
-Yeah, right?
-Yeah.
And, you know, it's --
I mean, I'm sure, you know,
you've heard this before.
That, like, the --
the good stuff, sort of,
it doesn't stick,
and the bad stuff,
you're just waking up
in the middle of the night,
tearing your hair out about it.
-It does.
It is true.
-I think it's better not to...
-Well, I can tell you,
as a friend, and after watching
you, you're fantastic in this.
-Thank you so much.
-Yeah, you're really great.
-Well, I am --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
-I'm not a critic.
-No, but I -- I am very --
I'm so proud
to be involved in this film.
You know, it's Rebecca Hall's
debut and...
-Yeah.
-...getting to work with her
and the lovely Tessa Thompson,
who is extraordinary
in this film, yes.
-Tessa Thompson
is fantastic, as well.
-Can we set it up?
Can we explain to everyone
what the film is about?
-So, "Passing"
is Rebecca Hall's debut film.
And she adapted it from a
novella written by Nella Larsen,
which was published in 1929.
And it's a story
based on two childhood friends
who bump into each other
in the lobby of a hotel.
And one is passing for White,
my character Clare,
and the other
is living in the Black community
with her Black family.
And it's about the --
how they're sort of enchanted
by one another's lives
and the different choices
they make, and how that
impacts them in the future.
It's kind of --
-It's -- It's beautiful.
-It is beautiful, isn't it?
-It's absolutely stunning.
-Yeah.
-And the story is beautiful.
And every -- and just
the performances, everything,
just top to bottom.
Congratulations.
It's so good.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ruth Negga
and Tessa Thompson in "Passing."
Take a look at this.
-Pardon me.
I don't mean to stare,
but I think I know you.
-I'm afraid you're mistaken.
-No.
Of course I know you, Reenie.
You look just the same.
Tell me,
do they still call you Reenie?
-Yes. Though no one's called me
that for a long time.
-Don't you know me?
[ Heel clicks ]
Not really really?
-I'm afraid
I can't seem to place...
-[ Laughs ]
-Clare?
-Mm-hmm.
That's right.
-Oh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ruth Negga, everybody!
-Oh, you're so sweet.
-Whatever you're doing,
don't stop.
-Thank you.
-"Passing" is streaming now
on Netflix.